Corea del Norte, la República islámica de
Irán o, sin ir más lejos, la amenaza nuclear
que Vladímir Putin ha repetido varias veces
desde que lanzara su desastrosa invasión
de Ucrania.
El riesgo nuclear ahora vuelve a estar sobre
la mesa.
Si la caída del Muro de Berlín el día 8
de noviembre de 1989, supuso que el mundo
se adentró en una era de paz,..
prosperidad y comercio.
Y los hongos nucleares, los simulacros de
bombardeos y los búnkeres excavados en las
profundidades de grandes montañas se convirtieran
en cosa del pasado.
Ahora, en cierto modo, ese tiempo parece terminado.
Y esto es algo que se refleja perfectamente
en noticias como estas:
(Es probable que China tenga 1.500 cabezas
nucleares en 2035: Pentágono.
Reuters)
(3 superpotencias nucleares, en lugar de 2,
marcan el comienzo de una nueva era estratégica.
China va camino de ampliar masivamente su
arsenal nuclear, justo cuando Rusia suspende
el último gran tratado de control de armamento.
Es el augurio de un nuevo mundo en el que
Pekín, Moscú y Washington serán probablemente
rivales atómicos.)
Y, ojo, porque como veremos, parece que el
propio gobierno de Vladimir Putin también
le está dando prioridad absoluta al rearme
nuclear.
Hablamos de un nuevo entorno político y militar
que está cambiando el equilibrio del poder
nuclear que se forjó en la Guerra Fría y
que ha hecho que en VisualPolitik nos hagamos
unas cuentas preguntas
¿Dónde y quienes tienen exactamente las
armas nucleares hoy en día?
¿Por qué con tantos frentes abiertos el
Kremlin parece estar haciendo del campo nuclear
su prioridad número 1?
¿Qué puede suponer esta nueva carrera?
Pues bien, en este vídeo os vamos a responder
a todas estas preguntas.
¡Arranquemos!
El miedo al desastre nuclear marcó gran parte
de la segunda mitad del siglo XX.
Tras la Segunda Guerra Mundial, poco a poco
más países fueron haciéndose con esta capacidad.
Por ejemplo, en 1949 La Unión Soviética
acabó con el monopolio de Washington, 1953
Reino Unido hizo lo propio y en 1964 llegaron
a la meta tanto Francia como China.
Sin embargo, con mucha diferencia, la Unión
Soviética y Estados Unidos fueron los dos
grandes protagonistas de toda esta historia.
Esto es algo que todos sabemos.
Entre ambos sumaron cerca del 70% del arsenal
nuclear y, tal y como podéis ver, han sido
responsables de 1.745 de los 2059 ensayos
nucleares que se han llevado a cabo en todo
el planeta.
Y es que no pensáis que cuando hablamos de
armas nucleares, hablamos de unas pocas decenas,
para nada.
Durante las primeras etapas de la Guerra Fría,
la Unión Soviética y Estados Unidos se pusieron
como locos a engordar más y más su inventario.
Por ejemplo, y para que os hagáis una idea,
en 1962 durante la crisis de los misiles en
Cuba, el botón rojo de la Casa Blanca contaba
ya con 25.540 cabezas nucleares.
Por aquel entonces la Unión Soviética “solo”
contaba con 3.346, pero pronto se pondría
las pilas hasta superar, al menos en números,
a la propia potencia norteamericana.
En total, en su punto álgido, a mediados
de la década de los 80, se estima que el
inventario mundial llegó a tener unas 70.000
cabezas nucleares.
¡De locos!
Y así, queridos amigos, es como se forjó
la conocida como doctrina de la Destrucción
Mutua Asegurada.
Es decir, tanto Estados Unidos como la Unión
Soviética habían ido tan lejos en la carrera
nuclear, que si por cualquier motivo uno atacaba
al otro, ambos quedarían aniquilados.
Ellos y quizás también buena parte del resto
del mundo.
Pero esto ya lo sabéis, es algo de lo que
se ha hablado hasta la saciedad.
Y lo cierto es que funcionó.
Quizás contra todo pronóstico, la doctrina
de la Destrucción Mutua Asegurada hizo que
el mundo fuera un lugar más seguro.
Ahora bien, ¿Sabéis qué problema había?
Imaginaos lo que supone tener decenas de miles
y miles de cabezas nucleares susceptibles
de que se produzca en cualquier momento un
malentendido, una operación terrorista o
error humano….
Y, ¡Zas!
El desastre de repente estaría servido y
no habría vuelta atrás.
Y evidentemente cuantas más armas tengas
más difíciles es controlarlas debidamente
y más probabilidades hay de que se produzca
un fallo.
Pues bien, precisamente por ese motivo, las
dos potencias entendieron que tenían que
hacer algo al respecto.
En concreto, alcanzar acuerdos para reducir
este peligro.
De esta forma, en 1968 nació el Tratado de
No Proliferación Nuclear, un acuerdo internacional
que freno en seco la carrera de muchos países
por dotarse de este tipo de ambas.
Y no solo eso, en 1972 se alcanzó el Tratado
de Limitación de Armas Estratégicas, el
SALT I.
Este acuerdo limitaba el número de misiles
balísticos intercontinentales y submarinos
balísticos tanto de Estados Unidos como de
la Unión Soviética.
Luego, en 1979 se fue más allá con la aprobación
del SALT II.
¿El resultado de estos acuerdos?
Pues fijaos:
Como veis, los tratados SALT abrieron la puerta
a la reducción de los arsenales nucleares.
Pero no fueron los últimos.
En el 87 las dos potencias firmaron un Tratado
para limitar las Fuerza Nucleares de Alcance
Intermedio y a partir de 1991, con la Unión
Soviética, ya disuelto, Rusia continuó con
la misma política sellando los acuerdos START
1 y 2, una versión mejorada de los SALT.
Claro que el descalabro de la Unión Soviética
y el colapso de su economía hizo que los
Estados Unidos volvieran a cobrar ventaja.
Sí, a ver, como habéis visto, Rusia tenía
más armas nucleares, pero muchos de ellas
eran antiguas, poco eficientes y las opciones
de lanzamiento eran mucho más restringidas.
Estados Unidos, en cambio, había logrado
desarrollar modernos bombarderos estratégicos
como el B2, submarinos nucleares y misiles
intercontinentales de mucha mayor precisión
y fiabilidad.
Y todo eso por no hablar de los nuevos sistemas
antimisiles como el THAAD.
Para los que no lo conozcais, el THAAD es
un sistema móvil diseñado para interceptar
misiles balísticos de medio y largo alcance.
El hecho de que sea móvil le permite proteger
grandes territorios o ciudades enteras.
Este sistema hace uso de un radar avanzado
para detectar y seguir los misiles enemigos,
transmitiendo su trayectoria en tiempo real
a otros sistemas de defensa antimisiles aliados.
Luego también está el Aegis, un sistema
similar pero operado desde buques de guerra.
Y sobre todo tenemos el sistema de intercepción
GMD, un sistema continental de defensa contra
misiles balísticos intercontinentales.
Un programa en el que Estados Unidos ha invertido
más de 100 mil millones de dólares desde
comienzos del siglo XXI y que ahora está
recibiendo mucha atención y partidas presupuestarias
récord.
Evidentemente, en estos campos la superioridad
económica y tecnológica de Estados Unidos
se nota.
Así que digamos que la Destrucción Mutua
Asegurada se pasó a una especie de Confianza
Mutua Asegurada, aunque lo cierto es que la
balanza estaba y está cada vez más desequilibrada
en favor de la potencia norteamericana.
(“Las características de los dos sistemas
de armas nucleares complicaban cualquier definición
viable de equilibrio.
Los sistemas estratégicos soviéticos eran
grandes e imprecisos, las armas estadounidenses
eran más transportables y precisas”.
Henry Kissinger en “Liderazgo”.)
Es por este motivo por lo que el Kremlin ha
empezado a preocuparse otra vez por ampliar
y renovar sus capacidades estratégicas.
Pero, antes de abordar esta cuestión, tenemos
que ver dónde estamos exactamente a nivel
global.
Este, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik, es
una radiografía del inventario actual de
la fuerza nuclear.
Atentos.
(T1: LAS ARMAS NUCLEARES DEL SIGLO XXI)
¿Queréis un dato sorprendente?
De unas 70.000 armas nucleares en todo el
mundo se ha pasado actualmente a menos de
14.000.
Y eso a pesar de que Pakistán, Israel, la
India y Corea del Norte se han sumado al club
nuclear.
De hecho, con la excepción de China, todas
las potencias nucleares históricas,
han reducido su arsenal atómico.
Para que os hagáis una idea, actualmente,
esta sería la estimación de armas nucleares
por países que podemos encontrar en todo
el mundo:
Como veis, la reducción paulatina de cabezas
nucleares continuó.
Desde la década de los 70 Estados Unidos
ha destruido cerca del 80% de su arsenal.
Y además de los acuerdos que ya hemos visto,
en 2010, el presidente de los Estados Unidos,
Barack Obama y el presidente de Rusia, Dmitri
Medvédev, firmaron en Praga el START III,
un nuevo tratado donde se contemplaba una
reducción adicional de un tercio del arsenal
de cada uno de los dos países.
Suponía eliminar cerca de 1750 cabezas nucleares
en cada uno de los dos inventarios.
En 2021 este acuerdo fue prorrogado 5 años
más, claro que su cumplimiento por parte
de Rusia está siendo muy cuestionado.
Eso sí, sea como sea, menos armas no quiere
decir menos capacidad.
Para que os hagáis una idea, el LGM-30G Minuteman
III de Estados Unidos y el RS-28 Sarmat ruso,
los misiles continentales por excelencia de
estos países, tienen cada uno una capacidad
destructiva entre 500 y 1500 veces superior
a la “Little boy” lanzada sobre Hiroshima
en 1945.
Pues bien, esta sería a grandes rasgos las
características básicas del inventario nuclear
del mundo.
Y, ojo, porque aquí tenemos que hacer un
apunte: países como Corea del Norte, pese
a que tiene un inventariwo muy pequeño, o
Irán si finalmente se hace con la bomba,
suponen un riesgo enorme, quizás mucho mayor
de lo que podríamos llegar a pensar.
¿Por qué?
Pues por lo que podemos denominar como el
riesgo de la informalidad.
Pensadlo bien, hablamos de dos países parías,
muy opacos, y con unas élites muy desconectadas
del resto del mundo.
2 países que, para colmo, están acostumbradas
a negociar con la fórmula de la presión,
el chantaje y la extorsión para conseguir
sus fines.
Estos países podrían por sí mismo provocar
el comienzo de un gran conflicto internacional.
Por ejemplo, se espera que en poco tiempo
Corea del Norte tenga la capacidad de atacar
directamente con misiles balísticos los Estados
Unidos, lo que le permitiría elevar cualquier
apuesta en una negociación…
Lo que se traduciría automáticamente en
mucha más tensión.
Y no hablemos ya de posibles fallos.
N3(9 feb 2023: Corea del Norte despliega suficientes
ICBM para abrumar el sistema de defensa estadounidense
contra ellos.
Administración tras administración han fracasado
en su intento de impedir que Corea del Norte
desarrolle un número tan elevado de misiles
balísticos intercontinentales que permitan
alcanzar Estados Unidos.
POLITICO)
Precisamente por esto y también por la aparición
de los nuevos misiles hipersónicos, ahora
El Pentágono está acelerando los planes
de desarrollo del sistema de defensa antimisiles,
como por ejemplo el sistema de intercepción
GMD que ya os hemos mencionado.
Incluso se están desarrollando prácticamente
desde cero nuevos interceptores.
Es lo que se conoce como el Proyecto del interceptor
de nueva generación.
Nuevos sistemas que en el futuro podrían
desplegarse en el resto de países aliados.
N4(La Agencia de Defensa contra Misiles solicita
10.900 millones de dólares para el año fiscal
24, y decenas de miles de millones más a
partir de entonces.
Breaking Defense)
Pero, ¿Os imagináis que entre tanto se produjera
un fallo y en unos años un misil de Corea
del Norte aterrizara no ya en Estados Unidos
sino en países como Japón o Corea del Sur?
Sería un desastre colosal y, sí, podría
terminar provocando un nuevo conflicto a gran
escala.
Pero más allá de estos riesgos que, ¿Qué
queréis que os diga?
Por remotos que sean resultan muy inquietantes,
ahora llegamos al punto clave:
La Guerra de Ucrania ha cambiado por completo
el panorama político y militar.
La pregunta, ¿dónde demonios nos encontramos
ahora exactamente?
¿Por qué decíamos al principio de este
vídeo que Putin tiene entre ceja y ceja la
fuerza nuclear?
Pues ahora mismo lo vamOs a ver.
(T2: ¿CÓMO SON LAS GARRAS DEL OSO RUSO MODERNO?)
Vladimir Putin relevó a Médvedev y regreso
a la presidencia en el año 2012, solo dos
años después de la firma del START III.
Y aunque el dictador ruso nunca dejo de ser
realmente quien mandaba y pese a que en 2021
estuvo a favor de extender 5 años su vigencia,
Putin siempre fue crítico con el desarme
nuclear.
Digamos que considera que esta es una vía
que busca someter al oso ruso y que por eso
la madre patria Rusia tiene que seguir otro
camino muy diferente.
¿Qué donde queda el acuerdo START III?
¿Qué más da?
Ya sabéis que el Kremlin solo cumple sus
compromisos cuando le conviene.
C2("A aquellos que en los últimos 15 años
han intentado acelerar una carrera armamentística
y buscar una ventaja unilateral contra Rusia
(...) todo lo que han intentado evitar con
esa política ya ha sucedido.
Nadie ha conseguido frenar a Rusia".
Vladímir Putin en 2018, tras anunciar una
nueva serie de avances en el arsenal nuclear
ruso.)
Y a ver, ¿Qué queréis qué os diga?
Desde un punto de vista de RealPolitik esta
posición tiene bastante sentido.
No creo que os sorprenda si os digo que es
evidente que la única fortaleza que hoy por
hoy tiene Rusia es su arsenal nuclear, sin
él esté país, no pintaría prácticamente
nada.
Hablamos de un país envejecido, con una economía
deprimida desde hace años y cuyo ejército
convencional no está siendo siquiera capaz
de derrotar al ejército ucraniano.
Por eso su única ventaja actualmente es la
amenaza nuclear.
O mejor, dicho, el chantaje nuclear.
N5(30 de enero de 2023: Boris Johnson asegura
que Putin lo amenazó con lanzar un misil
contra el Reino Unido, pero el Kremlin dice
que miente.
CNN)
N6(26 de abril de 2022: Lavrov advierte sobre
no subestimar amenaza de guerra nuclear.
Euronews)
En parte, estas amenazas es lo que hicieron
que la llegada de ayuda militar a Ucrania
no fuera tan rápida como probablemente hubiera
sido en un contexto diferente.
Y aunque no funcionaron del todo, es algo
que han repetido una y otra vez desde entonces.
N7(27 feb, 2023: Medvédev afirma que el suministro
de armas a Kiev podría provocar una catástrofe
nuclear mundial.
Reuters)
N8 (23 de marzo de 2023: Medvedev afirma que
crece la amenaza de una guerra nuclear.
AP)
Pero ¿Sabéis qué?
Aquí Rusia se enfrenta a dos grandes problemas:
por un lado, gran parte de su arsenal se esté
quedando obsoleto.
Ya habéis visto en Ucrania los enormes problemas
de tecnología, fiabilidad, obsolescencia,
suministro que tienen los equipos rusos.
Pues bien, en el campo nuclear la realidad
no tiene por qué ser diferente.
Por otro lado, está la apuesta norteamericana
para desarrollar sistemas antimisiles.
Si Estados Unidos consigue un sistema eficaz,
entonces la capacidad de disuasión de Rusia
se iría al garete.
C3(“Las presiones competitivas en el campo
de las armas nucleares estratégicas también
podrían verse condicionadas por la valoración
que haga Rusia de las capacidades de defensa
antimisiles de Estados Unidos.
Moscú ha demostrado que hará todo lo posible
y asumirá costes considerables para garantizar
que sus fuerzas nucleares estratégicas puedan
superar de forma fiable las defensas antimisiles
estadounidenses”.
Evaluación estratégica 2020 de la Universidad
de la Defensa Nacional de Estados Unidos)
Esto es lo que explica que en los últimos
años hayamos oído hablar tanto de nuevas
armas estratégicas y la razón por la que
el Kremlin decidió que un país pobre y con
una economía tan decadente como la rusa,
se destinará muchos recursos a nuevos submarinos,
misiles supersónicos y bombardeos estratégicos.
Que es exactamente lo que muchos habréis
visto en noticias como estas:
(17 de enero 2023: La Armada rusa recibe el
"arma del apocalipsis" mientras Putin cumple
su amenaza estratégica.
Poseidón es una de las armas de nueva generación
anunciadas por Moscú hace cinco años, con
capacidad para devastar ciudades costeras
y atacar grupos de combate navales sin ser
detectados.
El País)
(17 de febrero de 2023: Rusia probará un
nuevo misil hipersónico en simulacros con
China y Sudáfrica.
AP)
(3 de abril de 2023: Rusia está expandiendo
rápidamente su flota de submarinos nucleares.
Newsweek)
Y sí, ya sé lo que la inmensa mayoría estáis
pensando, pero vamos a ver Enrique, ¿qué
me estás contando?
Si los rusos ni siquiera están siendo capaces
de abastecer el frente.
¿Y qué pasa con las sanciones?
Pues sí es verdad, si algo ha quedado claro
en Ucrania es que las capacidades rusas son
como mínimo cuestionables.
Pero la cuestión es que esto sí es una gran
prioridad para el Kremlin.
Su capital político y quizás, incluso, su
propia supervivencia dependa de esta capacidad
de disuasión.
Y, ojo, que no solo hablo de Vladímir Putin,
ni tampoco me refiero exclusivamente a los
grandes equipos militares.
Fijaos.
C4(“Rusia está actualizando muchas de sus
armas nucleares de menor alcance, denominadas
"no estratégicas", e introduciendo nuevos
tipos (...) Parte de la justificación es
que las armas nucleares no estratégicas son
necesarias para contrarrestar la superioridad
de las fuerzas convencionales de la OTAN.”
Boletín de los Científicos Nucleares)
Es decir, hablamos de grandes armas que se
espera sean capaces de meter miedo en Estados
Unidos, y de otras armas más pequeñas y
fáciles de construir que pueden atemorizar
a la vieja Europa.
Y no olvidéis que con una negociación sobre
el conflicto de Ucrania pendiente, este tipo
de capacidades pueden ser muy importantes
a la hora de inclinar la balanza.
Pensadlo bien, si quieres presionar a Kiev,
¿Qué mejor que meter miedo a sus socios?
N12(26 de marzo de 2023: Putin dice que Moscú
colocará armas nucleares en Bielorrusia,
Estados Unidos reacciona con cautela.
Reuters)
El problema es que esto es algo nuevo.
Puede que penséis que la Unión Soviética
o Estados Unidos también utilizaron su enorme
arsenal nuclear para amenazar y atemorizar
a diestro y siniestro durante la Guerra Fría.
Pero lo cierto es que no fue así.
Digamos que este era un tema que se trataba
con mucho más cuidado y delicadeza.
La Unión Soviética nunca amenazó con utilizar
un arma nuclear en Afganistán, pese al apoyo
que los grupos opositores recibían de Estados
Unidos.
Ni en Afganistán ni en ningún otro lugar.
Y, por su parte, Estados Unidos tampoco amenazó
nunca con utilizar armas nucleares en Vietnam.
Es decir, es algo totalmente diferente a lo
que ahora está haciendo Putin, y también
Kim Jong-Un y quizás los Ayatolás si consiguen
la bomba.
Y esto es algo que hace saltar todas las alarmas.
¿La consecuencia inmediata?
Estados Unidos tendrá que tomarse mucho pero
que mucho más en serio la defensa antimisiles
y la no proliferación.
Lo que ocurre es que conseguir esto en Europa
puede resultar por un factor de distancia
y tiempo mucho más difícil.
¿Es posible desarrollar una especie de cúpula
de hierro?
Probablemente sí.
¿Costaría mucho dinero?
Muchísimo.
¿Debería Europa lanzarse a esta aventura?
Todo parece apuntar que sí.
La poca fiabilidad que está demostrando no
ya Pyongyang si no Moscú hacen que quizás
ya no baste con la mera disuasión.
Y la pregunta más importante: ¿Hará algo
Europa?
Probablemente no.
Y queridos amigos, amigas, esta es una de
las grandes bazas con la que Moscú sigue
contando para mantener su influencia y lograr
en el medio plazos nuevas concesiones.
Este es el motivo por el que, pese a todo
lo que está ocurriendo, Putin sigue erre
que erre con sus fuerzas nucleares.
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno para ti:
¿Hasta qué puntos consideras que el riesgo
nuclear ha vuelto a crecer?
¿Crees que lograra la Rusia de Putin mantener
su capacidad de disuasión?
¿Podrá Estados Unidos desarrollar de una
vez por todas un sistema de defensa antimisiles
que sea efectivo?
¿Cómo podemos protegernos o qué tenemos
que hacer ante las nuevas amenazas nucleares?
Dejadnos vuestras opiniones en los comentarios
y abramos debate.
Y ahora si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros a
VisualPolitik.
Una vez más muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.